c'est une maman qu'elle choisit de vous
poser une question docteur brigitte
virey vos quêtes pédiatre bonjour merci
d'être avec nous au jour alors cette
maman s'inquiète à la plusieurs enfants
d'âge différent elle n'est pas
institutrice et le problème c'est
qu'actuellement elle fait la classe à
ses enfants d'âge différent et c'est
plus que compliquée quels conseils vous
pédiatre vous pourriez donner à sandrine
s'il vous plaît oui c'est sûr c'est pas
très facile parce que c'est déjà pas
facile de devenir instituteur
institutrice professeur c'est
extrêmement compliqué donc pour une
maman qui était un petit peu loin de ça
même si elle suivait les devoirs de ces
enfants c'est pas du tout la même chose
de sublime devoir est de faire l'école
donc c'est difficile et s'est rendue
d'autant plus difficile que
effectivement souvent c'est des
connexions par internet 1 avec avec les
professeurs et donc quand il ya
plusieurs enfants à la maison baron n'a
pas forcément plusieurs écrans se
connecter
donc c'est un petit peu compliqué il
faut essayer de jongler devoir peut-être
un jour ce sera là un jour ce sera quand
c'est c'est c'est vraiment difficile
c'est difficile pour la maman de pouvoir
passer de l'un à l'autre et de de se
remettre dans le bain de tout ce qui est
et quand vous avez un enfant de 6 ans
qui apprend à lire et un autre qui en 6e
par exemple c'est pas du tout la même
chose et c'est finalement assez
compliqué et malheureusement
eh bien on peut difficilement dire des
choses parce qu'il faut avoir l'agilité
cérébrale pour voir passer de la nano
pouvoir est lié il faut aussi avoir les
connaissances et je ne suis pas sûr que
tout parent soit capable de refaire ce
qu'il a fait dans le temps alors pour
apprendre à lire à compter peut-être
mais quand on a des plus grands c'est
quand même assez compliqué et refaire
les cours de maths et de physique et
chimie
je pense qu'on ait beaucoup avoir oublié
il en était donc je pense qu'il faut
faire au mieux faut les aider faut les
encadrer faut les soutenir à leur
montrer qu'on est là comme toujours
c'est et discuter effectivement beaucoup
avec les professeurs de façon à ce
qu'ils donnent eux-mêmes les conseils
aux parents je crois que c'est ça qui
est important
et puis après ça on fait au mieux qu'on
peut et et c'est pas le métier des
parents donc faut pas qu'ils
s'inquiètent par rapport à ça bon on
n'est pas tous instituteur pas tous
institutrice tant que voilà ça peut être
un peu compliqué mais on est tous dans
le même banc et il faut qu'on à la
maison qu'il arrive on est tous au même
niveau
merci docteur brigitte virey pour votre
optimisme on se retrouvera une prochaine
fois je contiens d'accord at problème